[Musique]
chaque année un jury se réunit pour
élire les études scientifiques les plus
insolites de l'année et petit cocorico
pour petit cocorico pardon cette année
puisqu'une étude française a été
récompensé dans la catégorie économie
mon cher emmanuel lechypre un chercheur
de montpellier a prouvé qu'il y avait un
lien entre le poids des hommes
politiques et le niveau de corruption
d'un pays il s'est intéressé à 15 pays
d'europe de l'est et a montré que plus
les dirigeants et têtes et paie plus la
corruption était élevée dans le pays il
ya une étude que j'ai vu cette année et
qu'il n'a pas été primé c'est celle ci
des scientifiques qui ont appris à des
épinards à envoyer des emails c'est fou
de se dire qu'il ya des épinards qu'ils
sont capables de faire des choses que
certains de nos téléspectateurs ne sont
pas capables de faire je salue tous les
gens qui m'écrivent encore d'être fait
dans la catégorie médecine le nobel
insolite revient aux chercheurs qui ont
prouvé qu avoir un orgasme était aussi
efficace qu'un spray nasal pour se
déboucher le nez et astucieux n'avait
pas de spray nasal sous la main si vous
avez aimé boucher ce matin vous savez ce
qu'il vous reste à faire et vive la
science lorsque karine le marchand se
demande le portrait de ta femme pulpeuse
au grand méchant je me suis reconnue
franchement elle est très tôt à mon
époque voilà les femmes c'était dans les
magazines qui avait un seul standard de
famille avait un seul modèle de féminité
il y avait cette injonction à être douce
a pas parlé fort il y avait cette
injonction être belle vous rendez compte
sur connaît enfin le chemin qu'on a fait
quand on voit les marques de mode qui
maintenant rechercher des parts ou des
femmes de tous âges de toutes formes et
tout à fait merveilleux moi je trouve
qu'on a fait un pas de géant voilà vous
savez que kim kardashian l'invité à
l'habiller gratos par des marques de
haute couture chacune de ses sorties et
ça fait souvent remarquer par ses tenues
à la pointe de la mode là je dois vous
avouer que sa dernière sortie a provoqué
chez moi une interrogation j'ai pas
compris je vous laisse apprécier
regardez c'est à sa belle et la voilà
tout un voilà c'est particulier quand
même hein c'est à dire comme ben oui oui
alors quatre points version sur le
retour quoi à un autre mec en moins
testo
année
épilogue votre dernier spectacle vous
faisiez sanglant de regretter à 45 ans
de n'avoir jamais été harcelés top 10
donc c'est un poil vexant disant
produite par gilbert rozon rien rien
quoi il n'en fut rien les castings pour
le cinéma les producteurs pas ils m'ont
jamais prise les sens du terme
et ben voila j'ai fait le bisous
des bisous bisous
des bisous j'étais à toulouse vous faire
un bisou magique dans le coup a imaginé
le scandale ah oui cyril féraud embrasse
une candidate dans le cou un scandale on
a aujourd'hui pour les toutes les jeunes
femmes des modèles positifs auxquels
s'identifier oui c'était très négatifs
qui sont
inquiets que la réalité quand même bon
c'est ça qui est bizarre dans cette
société c'est qu'à un antagonisme
incroyable entre entre deux modèles de
féminité qui sont super éloigné quoi je
voudrais en fruits et légumes commençant
par la lettre e
un aigle en chine mais non églantine
fille la mandarine c'est pas bon mia 5 4
3 2
au top une endive mais nathan a alors là
je crie au scandale
bon alors qu elle félicitée la
tenniswoman leila fernandez pour ses
performances à l' us open elle nous a
offert le lapsus du week end on la sent
passionnés et c'est très commenté ça
c'est contagieux j'ai envie de dire que
sa passion pour le tennis c'est le pénis
puisqu'il
tient ma vaisselle si tu sais pas encore
osé les chéris
mais vous avez des fonctionnaires toute
votre vie kaka instituteurs étaient des
fonctionnaires
les policiers dans la rue sont des
fonctionnaires l'électricité avec
laquelle google assure que la
badea ya des gens qui fait honneur à
votre intelligence en sable donner des
choses mais ces solutions que ce que je
dérange pas ce que vous ressentez le
besoin de m'interrompre en général quand
on n'est pas dérangé on interrompt mais
parce que sinon c'était un dialogue vous
êtes transmettre à vos enfants et
pour avancer il faut écraser l'autre
voilà
[Applaudissements]
deux places sur un ring
vous vouliez rejoindre l'alliance
bolivarienne et quitter l'otan moi je
préfère rester dans le temps et les cds
j'avoue que vous ne savez pas ce que
l'alliance bolivarienne qui n'a rien à
voir avec les eaux tandis que vous aimez
chine ignorant c'est dommage parce que
vous êtes intelligent brillant jeu vous
pourriez faire des études et à améliorer
en continu et je pense que j'ai fait des
merveilles depuis que je sais c'est pas
grave
[Musique]
j'aime
monsieur gucci béhanzin est vraiment le
fils naturel de toutes ces politiques
folle d'immigration et de naturalisation
qui font qu'un type qui a été multi
condamné nommer leur côté qu'ils passent
sans rien lâcher sur la france non non
je n'essaye la france
je vous dis je viens sur la chance non
je ne vous en dis rien sur la liste et
moi
je crache
sur le système comme annoncé la semaine
dernière trump a donc bel et bien
commenté un combat de boxe samedi le
jour des 20 ans du 11 septembre et voici
comment son fils également de la partie
a tenté de justifier sa race
la scène s'est déroulée au hard rock
stadium de miami samedi lors d'une
rencontre universitaire de foot
américain un chat cascadeur a voulu
faire une entrée à la johnny par le toit
du stade sauf que lui n'avait pas
d'hélicoptère un chat suspendu dans le
vide il tombe avant d'être sauvé miracle
par deux spectateurs qui a amorti sa
chute grâce à un drapeau la scène est
devenue virale évidemment sur les
réseaux sociaux et tout le monde va bien
je vous rassure
le salsifis on ne mord pas sa maman
allait
alors bon attendez est-ce que vous allez
supporter un arrêt technique art est
gentil ou leila deen là il est il alors
quand il évident comme ça il est puni
elle est au revoir mais qu'est ce qu'ils
font et c'est quand même pas des manger
en maintenant nos visions
boyle
non mais oh oh non je te jure ouais bah
merde ça ça va hurler tu vas voir
non mais c'est un monde